stops a 10-0 milwaukee run
but see what happens too is when you get
a score and i was going to say
you can set your defense but miami
didn't set anything
unable to hit that three-pointer
four-point game giannis
shakes it off he thought about it and
said no i'm not quite ready to go yet
but now he is he gets a switch with hero
on him
forbes long range three on its way and
now they're down seven which is a
14-point swing in favor of milwaukee
with more to come right here
and middleton misses the land but the
putback by brook lopez
you don't see that or expect that from
the miami heat
in particular on the defensive end of
the court but that's what we've
been seeing in the third quarter another
one was pleading his case
it was prior to the shot middleton's had
a great third quarter
[Music]
just over matching third quarter not
getting back on defense after you scored
and you're giving up look you down
udonis has understands it it's not the
x's and o
okay unforced turns